well the business and trade secretary
Kami badenog joins me now very good
morning to you good to see you so
Britain is joining the CPT PPP I've been
practicing that just how big a deal do
you think this is it's a it's a very big
deal uh and it's not about what's going
to happen tomorrow it's really uh a
strategic play for the future we in the
government uh have had an indo-pacific
tilts you would have heard all about the
uh integrated review what we're going to
be doing with our economy on security
issues and so on and basically the the
Crux of the matter is that Global growth
is going to be coming from this region
in just about seven years about 40 of
the global middle class will be in the
indo-pacific and what we want to do is
to be able to create new Pathways so we
can trade more freely because that's
where that's where the business is going
to be coming from and yeah you talk
about of business in the future and yet
according to the government's own
estimate this deal will only add 0.08
onto the country's growth and that's
over around 10 years or so and that's a
lot less than the four percent hit we've
had from brexit According to yes
those figures aren't just the
government's figures they're my own
Department's figures and that it asks
the exact same question well why are we
doing this if this is just 0.90 and then
they gave the context to the figures it
was a scoping assessment done two years
ago based on 2014 Figures it's sort of a
rough draft of where you want to start
from but the thing I would want your
viewers to understand is this is not to
replace EU trade it's in addition to uh
EU trade we have a an EU FDA every day
we're working to make it better but
we're also able to do more on the
outside of the EU and that's what this
is about so people should look at those
projections in terms of buying a startup
which is going to grow and become huge
in the future it doesn't it's not about
what it's making today but about the
potential that synergies and that's why
it's really exciting but also we do have
trade deals with nearly all of these
countries already don't we so how much
difference can this make because the the
what's in them is is different so the
bilateral trade deals are different from
a multilateral trade deal you create
synergies it's uh it's it's well it's
the first time we've joined a block like
this in about in about 50 years there is
strength in in numbers and yes we have
uh remember we have a relationship with
the EU already we've got an FDA so this
is adding uh this is adding to that but
we don't have relation uh an FDA with
all of those countries but the key thing
is that more countries are joining and
we've got in early so again it's about
that potential and about uh changing
things like tariff rules we had free
trade agreements with those countries
but now 99
um of our exports are going to be Tower
free we didn't have that with the
previous trade deals but what is the
risk that there could be Imports that
come in that go against some of our
standards our food standards for example
or on ethical students okay what about
our ethical stances so let me so so on
uh on things like food standards and
Epic standards the difference between
this and being in the EU is that we make
the rules and regulations on our
standards we have quotas which say what
the amounts are but people have to meet
our standards and that's that's what's
good about it well so what about palm
oil from Malaysia and for example palmol
obviously it is seen to be responsible
for destroying habitats being very bad
for the environment you're saying that
there won't be lower tariffs on palm oil
coming in but there are there are that's
what happens you have to make trade-offs
but we take in already just about one
percent I think it's actually slightly
less than one percent of Malaysian palm
oil uh palm oil ex exports moving the
turret from two percent to zero percent
is not what's going to cause
deforestation and actually the standards
which are set by this government by the
Departments for uh the environment is
what's going to dictate what comes in
what comes into the country but also
being in the trade block means that
you're going to have more influence on
sustainability palm oil is actually a
great product it's in so many of the
things we use this is not some illegal
substance since we're talking about and
actually there were there are other
crops in the EU that are causing
deforestation that fit within e-rule so
we need to do what is right for our
country and make the decisions which are
going to be of benefit to the Future and
help to influence those things that we
want to change so I think it's still uh
overall a very good thing what about
Farmers they might be worried they have
felt that the trade deal that was done
by the government with Australia and New
Zealand meant that they had to compete
with under under what they might see as
a ruinous conditions so do they have to
be worried about this deal as well no
not at all um I would say that I think
that the concerns about the previous
deals were overblown but I took that
feedback uh when I was going into the
negotiations I'm an MP for a rural
constituency I speak to Farmers all the
time and I had them at the back of my
mind when we were carrying out these
negotiations so for instance on things
like beef and pork what we're talking
about is five percent of uh domestic
consumption that's not that's not going
to displace farmers in the UK and a lot
of that is already coming from uh other
countries in the EU so actually it's
more competition for EU countries and at
the end of the day people don't have to
buy what they don't want if I'm
negotiating a trade deal I'm thinking
about my my farmers in my country and
what I can do for them we will only grow
our agriculture in this country if we
export and we can't tell people we want
to export our farm products but we don't
want any of theirs that's not how trade
works it's for Mutual benefit okay I
want to ask you um you know as well as
business secretary and trade secretary
you're also Minister for women
inequalities and a report has come out
today looking into fire services in
England and it's found that staff at a
quarter of them have reported alleged
racist homophobic and misogynistic
behavior in the past five years what do
you make of those funds it's terrible
it's extremely disappointing to hear
obviously there's no way that one can
make excuses for that I think it needs
to be investigated what is happening
what is causing the culture that is
creating these outcomes in the fire
service but I would also ask people to
look at things like the the government's
plan on um uh strategy on Race for
instance inclusive Britain there are
many recommendations that we have there
for organizations in terms of looking at
their work culture and they still work
that we are doing which hopefully will
be able to use to help improve uh the
working environment for places like the
the fire service it is unacceptable that
people should go into the workplace and
have those sorts of experiences and I
will do everything I can within my power
to be able to support you yes what will
you do to try to help change the culture
well um what I specifically on Race
because that's something that I have
worked on we have we set out what can be
done and we still have some things in
training which I'll be announcing uh
probably when we come back from from
Recess gives an update on the report but
more importantly there are already laws
that will be able to help tackle tackle
those those issues so there there are
there are Court remedies is the equality
and Human Rights Commission but more
importantly we need to understand why
this is happening what is happening with
the culture and we're very ready uh as a
department to support to support the
fire service but without knowing the
detail I can't really comment much
further than that Denise broke last
night that a grand jury in the States
has uh voted to indict Donald Trump he
says he's the victim of a political
Witch Hunt um are you confident all the
proper legal processes are being
followed there
I don't know enough about the US I
thought I should hope so um they are a
close country
um and uh I think our closest they're
like I think it's important that we just
continue to maintain our working
relationship uh with the US uh and
wherever uh they have a due process
they're looking to make sure that it is
followed we have to set an example to
other countries but to be honest I don't
know very much about Donald Trump or
this specific case and I will assume
that like any live court case it's not
something that we can comment on as the
proceedings uh go on but and yet it's a
bit big moment isn't it a former
president one who has still has
political Ambitions he'd love to return
to be president it's a big moment to see
them criminally indicted it's it it's
it's it's huge um if what we're seeing
is going to play out it's it's
absolutely huge but I don't uh I don't
really like talking about Donald Trump
to be honest I like talking about the UK
and what we're doing here for British
people okay well Cami bednak thanks very
much indeed for coming in today thank
you to chat to us about those issues
thank you